Finley's yumin please find your seats
while you listen very well thank you
welcome welcome to plaster auditorium
isn't this a beautiful place I can't
wait for you to see the chapel if you've
not gone just to stand outside you have
to do that it just takes your breath
away not even going inside just the
outside part unbelievable
it is my pleasure to introduce this
afternoon's speaker dr. Victor Davis
Hanson dr. Hanson is the Wayne and
Marcia bush ski to ski Distinguished
Fellow of history at Hillsdale College
he is also a senior fellow at the Hoover
Institution and a professor of classics
emeritus at California State University
Fresno here in his BA at the University
of California Santa Cruz and his PhD in
classics from Stanford University in
2007 he was awarded the National
Humanities medal and in 2008 he received
the Bradley prize from the Lynde and
Harry Bradley Foundation he's written
for numerous publications including the
Claremont Review of Books the New
Criterion and the Wall Street Journal he
is the author of several books including
a war like no other how the Athenians
and Spartans fought the Peloponnesian
War and the Second World War the first
global conflict was won or fought and
won ladies and gentlemen please help me
warm normally bring up dr. Victor Davis
Hanson
thank you very much for coming out this
is the 16th year I've taught at
Hillsdale and I live on a farm in
central California I never tell anybody
where I'm going so my wife said the
other day one of our neighbors farmers
said did he go to that weird place again
and when does he come back so I have a
kind of a stealth life here that nobody
knows about have you ever asked herself
if you were to describe yourself and can
you imagine if you said I'm a
nationalist compared to if you said I'm
an internationalist what if your child
came home instead of saying I major in
IR international relations they said I
majored in in our nationalist relations
you can imagine the pushback you would
get what I'm getting at is nationalism
is not a good word at least until the
last two years that's kind of peculiar
because the word comes from the Latin
not EO and it was considered even an
antiquity a progressive idea that unlike
the Greek city-state were people of the
same language roughly the same
traditions the same ethnic background
were politically fragmented in Italy
they came up with a new concept of
unification and they thought that that
would be a more equitable and successful
way of solving rivalries between
different people so what happened to the
concept Woodrow Wilson remember went to
Versailles in January of 1919 promising
that people who spoke the same language
and had the same ethnic background and
mostly the same religion would get to
have their own national destiny they
would not be subject to imperial rule by
others so what happened I think very
briefly the answer is Germany until the
French Revolution sort of gave a
catalyst to the modern idea of
nationalism the Congress of Vienna but
the unification of Germany creating the
largest country in Europe
Warp the idea of nationalism because it
was a little bit different than the
other european countries and by that I
mean it was involved in three wars the
franco-prussian war of 1871 it invaded
through Denmark Belgium and France in
1914 and of course it went into Poland
in 1939 on September 1st and triggered
World War two but it wasn't just people
felt that Germany was aggressive but
people felt that they had redefined
nationalism by that I mean even before
National Socialism of the 1930s there
was a movement in Germany that said that
Germans are going to be defined by Blut
boater blood and soil and what that
meant was you could live in Germany
within the boundaries of Germany you
could speak German you could be a sixth
generation German you could be a
Lutheran or Catholic but you would not
be German if you didn't have a
particularly sheíll ancestry and that
goes back to the 19th century when
writers said that and we're how did that
happen in Germany and not France and the
answer was that in antiquity Rome which
was a multiracial society like her own
had incorporated most of Western Europe
and to some degree Northern Europe but
not Germany the Romans felt that these
people were very fierce they were beyond
the Danube and the Rhine and they were
going to be let be you read Tacitus is
essay on ancient Germany the germani and
he says there are very different people
and what had been sort of deprecated ori
in antiquity became was flipped upside
down after the net the unification of
germany is that we were better because
we were never mongrelized and that sort
of discredited the idea of nationalism
because in Italy
Mussolini's said we have La Raza with
twosies kind of scary because that has a
modern connotation and then funko wrote
a novel General Franco in Spain called
La Raza believe it or not and they both
parroted the Nazi idea that you couldn't
Spanish in Italian even if you spoke
Italian or Spanish and you lived here in
yet and unless you had a racial essence
and by the way if you look at the
Constitution of Mexico today it does
says that immigration shall not impair
the racial equilibrium of Mexico so what
I'm getting at is there's a strain of
nationalism that has polluted the
otherwise positive view of nationalism
and it's too bad because if you're going
to organize people people are not born
homogeneous there's not a homogeneity
that's natural so if you're gonna
organize different people under a
political framework there's a limited
amount of choices you can use force
force of religion like the Caliphate of
the 14th century or the Ottoman Empire
Caliphate and force people to be Muslims
of all different races and nationalities
or you can be the the Soviet Union and
say you may be Chechnya or Ukraine in
but you're a Marxist Leninist first of
all or yuccas Lobby as long as Tito is
alive and says we're all communists
we're not Serbs or Bosnia if you don't
use that Imperial coercion then you can
do what Wilson thought was a liberal
idea you can allow people to create
national boundaries based on their race
and you can have several of them there
can be an independent survey or Bosnia
and you can have this ethnic state and
as long as it treats its neighbors ok
Luther Way Nia treats Estonia ok there's
no problem usually that doesn't happen
very often in history and there's a
third alternative and it's very rare and
that is to combine people of different
races and ethnic backgrounds increase
into one country and not use coercion
the Rome pulled it off for a few
centuries and nobody has except us and
so what unites people in this audience
that do not look like each other is a
common national story the Constitution
the Bill of Rights the 4th of July the
Gettysburg Address and the notion that
Faulkner or Stein book Steinbeck or the
last of the Mohicans does not belong to
any particular race or creed
an American idea it's a melting pot and
it has to be worked upon all the time
because it's not a natural phenomenon
it's a construct that we in the melting
pot will unite people by ideas and that
means that Americans can look like
anyone none of you in this audience can
go to Japan and say I am Japanese even
if you're legally Japanese you'll never
be fully accepted the same is true of
China
I don't think Condoleezza Rice could be
Chancellor of Germany today I just don't
think it's going to happen we're the
only country that's pulled this off and
the key to this net this benign are good
nationalism is citizenship the idea that
the American citizen is unique and I'm
very worried because I think citizenship
is eroding and it's becoming meaningless
and with it nationalism is disappearing
in the positive sense and it's happening
in a very strange way on two levels I
guess we would call some of us pre
citizens in some of the most post
citizen and what's common is we forgot
who sit at how citizenry develop it it
occurred for the first time in the
seventh century in ancient Greece and
you know the word Polat takes a citizen
you get political policy even police and
it was elaborated on and
institutionalized in Rome as the kiwis
the Civic a sidess Civic civil
civilization and the idea is at a
particular resident within these
boundaries was not a subject of a king
or dictator and he wasn't a wild
tribesman up in Gaul or Scandinavia he
was a unique person who could pass on
property to his children he could vote
he could make his own laws and he had
the choice when and where to live and
how long he was a free person in other
words he that seems self-evident now it
was a very rare there was nothing like
it in the Near East
nothing like it in Sumeria Egypt nothing
like it in tribal northern Europe it was
a unique idea nothing like it in the new
world
Aztecs no Mayans no but now what we're
trying to do I guess in this country
either by laxity or by intent is revert
back to pre citizenship and it occurs at
at three levels the first is we're
blurring the line between a mere
resident and a citizen we have about 60
million residents in the United States
largest number we've ever had that are
not US citizens there's no problem with
40 million because they have green cards
and they're illegal even though that's a
hard large number to assimilate
intermarry and integrate into the body
politic something we should watch what
we have according to the Yale and MIT
latest study about 20 million people who
are here illegally and the strange thing
about it is that the chief and
ingredients of American citizenship that
said an American citizen and only
American citizen can leave or enter the
country as he pleases or vote in an
election as he wishes or stay
indefinitely in the United States due to
his legal rights has been completely
blurred where I live in California if
you're here illegally
you can go back across the border as you
wish in San Francisco if you're here
illegally you can vote in school board
elections and the same is true in some
places in New England and as we learned
with the daca and dreamer program you
can live here indefinitely
and it even is a little bit more extreme
than just equality with citizenship
sometimes it's mirror it's it's mere
discrimination a person in California
who's charged with a crime if the person
is a resident rather than a citizen is
not subject to federal immigration law
to the full extent if you are I come
into the Detroit Airport from overseas
we do not have a passport we're going to
be detained if you are in Fresno County
and 500 other sanctuary city
jurisdictions and you commit a crime and
you're here illegally you're not going
to be deported it's not going to happen
you're given a privilege as it is if
you're in California and you are here
illegally you're going to get a license
just like a citizen but not quite just
like a citizen because the federal law
says for you to travel you have to have
proof of citizenship to get a proper ID
for the federal transportation authority
so that means that all the citizens in
California have to turn in their
driver's licenses
next year and reapply with a passport in
other words they have an extra burden to
pay because residents had an advantage
of not having to have the same type of
ID for their for their version of
driver's license
so in some sense in many of our states
it doesn't really matter whether you're
a citizen or resident and you can see
where that's leading people who come
from different countries and they're
here illegally they have no investment
to the same degree as we do in our
constitutional documents they don't
really want to know part of the national
story where I live people candidates
from south of the border fly into the
Central Valley of California campaign
and people vote for them and they vote
in the United States you can see the
problem and fragmenting society because
what the theme is that were of various
different races and ethnic backgrounds
and this is not normal in history and we
have to make the extra effort but we're
not making extra effort we're doing just
the opposite but besides turning into a
country of mere residents were also
becoming a country of tribes and by that
I mean the idea of multiracialism that
we're all of different races but we
share a common culture is eroding and
now we're becoming many cultures and
many races Stanford University you can
determine the racial background of your
roommate before you enroll the same as
to a Claremont College there are places
on university campuses called safe
spaces that are reserved for particular
people and of a particular race there
are themed houses and dorms where people
segregate according to their race there
was a reason
did anybody ask herself why for years
Elizabeth Warren and other politicians
had railed against white privilege if
that were true why would Elizabeth
Warren choose to be a Native American
that
culturally-appropriate a another
identity which according to her own
logic would put her at a disadvantage
giving the ubiquity of white privilege
and the answer is that we have returned
to the one-drop rule of the old south
that one drop 1/16 allows you to become
in a minority so the reason that she
said she was a Cherokee person a member
of the Cherokee Nation is she wanted a
careerist advantage over someone else
who chose not to play that game and
Harvard was only happy to comply because
the law school bragged that she was
their first minority a Native American
faculty member and so what you can see
is a retry belies a ssin of America at
the expense of citizenship I went to
school in a grammar school that was
about 90% mexican-american and maybe it
was culturally insensitive
maybe the melting pot got too hot but we
took people from all over Latin America
and we made them into American citizens
and I've noticed I'm 66 that when I see
some people that I went to kindergarten
at first grade that be they went from
Wanda Johns and they dropped the accent
on their last name now in their 60s
they're back to wanna gay and they've
added accents and - nations to their
name and what would be the purpose of
that the purpose is they get a general
impression from the society at large
that there's an advantage not to
identify just as a plain old American
that you have to be a tribal a member of
a particular tribe the LGBT community
the asian-american community the black
community and you can see where this is
going 70% of the country's self
identifies as white and the last thing
you would want would be 70% of the
country to start identifying as white it
would be the worst thing in the world to
happen but that's the logic of tribalism
that leads something to something like
Rwanda or the former Yugoslavia or what
we saw in Iraq so we have to be careful
of people blurring the line between a
citizen and a resident and an American
and a tribal member there's another
there's another phenomenon it's just as
scary that's going on and
theme a pre citizenship America was
based on the viability of a middle class
if you read the essays of Jefferson he
said you know when we pile up everybody
into the cities and they're no longer
farm owners then we'll have two classes
wealthy and poor if you read st. john
dickricker Crevecoeur or you read Alex
de Tocqueville the theme is the same
that a solid property owning middle
class has advantages over the poor
because they're invested in a particular
place they showed a sobriety of judgment
to save their money they're stationary
people they're sober judicious they do
not look to government to the same
degree as the poor and unlike the
wealthy they don't have the power or
leverage to effect government to act in
the interests of a small clique so there
was this romance and it was easy to do
because 90% of the country as I said
were agraria we survived the Industrial
Revolution the middle class did I should
say and it was transmogrified into the
American ideal that everybody would own
a home and they would have a job that
would open a pathway to upward mobility
and they'd have an avenue to go to
college for self-improvement and out of
that matrix they would be independent
and autonomous people and all of us the
in the middle class then could tell the
poor we're not gonna redistribute money
and we could also tell the very wealthy
and you're not going to be a crony
inside capitalist what's happened though
we've psychologically deprecated the
middle class or elites say that the
middle class lacks the culture of the
wealthy with our snowmobiles and SUVs
and jet skis and Winnebagos and we don't
have the romance of the distant poor and
that reflects something that in actual
terms the middle class is threatened
homeownership peaked right before the
collapse in 2008 at 71% it's down to
about 62% but unfortunately that doesn't
tell the whole story the percentage of a
family budget that goes to housing has
gone from about 14% in the 1950s to 44%
so people to the degree that they can
buy a house are spending nearly half
their income wages until two years ago
had been frozen for ten years the middle
class didn't really see an increase in
their wages for tenure it's gone up
three percent under Trump but until then
it had not gone up and when you talk
about college and upward mobility and
this is a very apropos topic here at
Hillsdale because the purpose of this
wonderful gala is to raise money to help
defray the cost of tuition but we have
an aggregate 1.6 trillion dollars in
student debt I don't think we're getting
much returned from most colleges if you
look at the level of education that a
recent graduate shows but more
importantly there were certain
attributes about the middle class
allowed citizens to be traditional and
to be participants in the American story
and one was of course people got married
quite early in the 20s the average age
until 1952 was 22 some of you got
married at 21 or 22 until just 2000 the
average number of children is it was
about 2.1 it's now about 1.7 people are
an average getting married about 29 now
I mentioned housing going down in middle
class of wages and student debt was
about 5% of students had student debt in
the 50s and so think what we're doing
we're telling young people you're really
not going to be able to buy a house and
you're an indentured servant to your
former college that you have this
$200,000 debt and they say I'm not I
can't afford to get married I'm not
going to have children I can't go to the
suburbs I don't want to live in a town
like Hillsdale I want to live in a farm
I want to be a hipster in a urban
environment and get and that's pretty
much the ingredients of what you see on
the news with an T fall that's the
profile so the destruction of the middle
class and turns you into a nation of
peasants as we see in California we're
almost 1 out of 1 out of 5 and we're
getting close to 1 out of 4
lives below the poverty line and yet we
have the largest number of zip codes of
people who were in the most affluent
counties in the country we have the
highest number of billionaires but if
you drive up to Stanford University on
any given day you'll see people living
in Winnebagos right out in front of
campus can't afford to buy a home and
they're working for Google or Facebook
or Yahoo or Apple with a market
capitalization of four trillion dollars
I I submit to you that that's not a good
way to create a stable American
nationalist patriotic country when
you're destroying the middle class so we
don't want to be mere residents or
tribes people or peasantry but I'd like
to suggest that on the other end of the
scale there's on the elite side there's
just as much danger to nationalism as in
citizenship our elite tend to believe on
the coast that they're not citizens so
much of the United States as citizens of
the world they like to be called
international store globalist they do
not want to be known as nationalists
they have more faith in the Paris
climate Accord or the Kyoto agreements
than they do their own government
they're ashamed of the Second Amendment
when they go to Europe they feel the
trans-pacific trade is much better than
negotiating individual trade deals
there's they love the World Bank they
love the International Monetary Fund
they think the UN Commission on civil
rights or human rights has more
authority than does the US House of
Representatives
and out of that it's an old idea out of
that comes a transnationalism that just
as globalization took american free
market capitalism and spread it around
is seven billion people and gave us
instant communications instant travel
almost anybody can get on a phone and
call any of the other 7 billion people
in the world almost quite easily but
what did not follow was American
constitutional government most people
said that is too strange it's too weird
we don't want it and by that they meant
they don't like the second
they've been Western Europeans and most
of the world
they have no problem with late term
abortion they feel the government should
intervene and restructure radically the
economy on the theory of manmade global
warming and so there's a lot of ideas
out in the globalized world that are
antithetical to Americas and we have a
lot of people in the country who in the
progressive movement feel that we have
to move beyond Americanism enjoying the
world just as we have economically and
culturally there's a second thing that's
happening with post citizenship and
that's a formal assault on the US
Constitution by the elite classes by
that I mean we've now had a second
election in which as the framers
envisioned from time to time the
candidate who won the popular vote might
not win the electoral college it
happened with George W Bush and Al Gore
too happened with Hillary Clinton and
don't keep from unfortunately both in
both cases progressives lost and given
the Trump trajectory people are very
angry and they think the answer to it is
to change either the Constitution or the
accepted custom and practice of the last
hundred years we mentioned sanctuary
cities I would just say that Noah
focaccia is a very common Creed now in
the United States but it's only goes one
way you can nullify federal immigration
law but believe me if the people of
Provo Utah decide that within their
jurisdiction they want to nullify
federal handgun registration they're not
going to be able to do it if people in
Bakersfield say the Endangered Species
Act does not apply in Kern County
they're not going to be able to do it
it's a one-sided asymmetrical view sort
of like South Carolina in 1832 and three
when they nullify federal law and said
tariff policy doesn't apply it's a road
to perdition as we know from 1861 and
yet it's getting more and more common
that a particular jurisdiction can defy
and legally so the US Constitution
people want to return to FDR's
half-baked plan of packing the court I
don't know if they think they're gonna
get away with it FDR didn't but if you
look at court decisions after the court
packing scheme of the late 30s you could
make the argument that justice tend to
be a little bit more progressive in fear
that they might either have more
justices or face mandatory retirements
so there's an effort at least to suggest
we're going to change the nature of the
court and even if we can't that's a
message to you conservative people to
shape up or else there's an idea that as
you know every single candidate that I
know of that I've heard my check today
is in favor of abolishing in the
electoral college people don't
understand what it was for it was for to
give equal representation to people
outside big cities and follow the
Republican model of Rome and not the
quite scary 51 percent get what they
want in any given day plan of ancient
Athens and yet that's very common in
preparation for this talk I did a lot of
research I didn't realize how common it
is the progressive anger at the US
Senate and a common refrain as the
people of Wyoming have two senators each
represents two hundred and forty-five
thousand people we in California have
two sinners each represents twenty
million people that's not fair let's
make senators proportion on the
population as House members and I think
we'll see some of that in short there's
a formal assault on the Constitution
because it hasn't given the expected
results and because the aims of the left
are so exalted and noble they feel that
any means necessary are justified and
finally there's an informal effort to
create something like a post citizen
that doesn't have to abide by the
Constitution
have you noticed we have still have a
Second Amendment but what does it mean
if you're in a rural part of the United
States and you go to Walmart and they
can't sell you immune
in other words social justice warriors
that cancel culture social media
Hollywood the foundations the
universities that all of them can put
such pressure on people that they can't
fully exercise their constitutional
rights even though the rights day yury
are still in existence if you're a cake
maker and you don't want a particular
theme of a sexual orientation you can
can be coerced if your cartr page and
you're innocent but you represent an
unattractive candidate or campaign you
can be leveraged by a prosecutor or if
you're Michael Flynn you can plead be
pled guilty ninety 90 percent of all
federal prosecutors when their cases to
all cases of federal prosecutors do so
we have to be very careful that we're
not creating a situation while it's we
still have these personal freedoms
protected by the Constitution
we can't exercise them I know as a
professor and fellow at Stanford I speak
to a lot of students and I will
guarantee you that if you were students
now at Stanford I would not say the
following because I wouldn't get I
wouldn't get to the end of the speech if
I said I'm very skeptical about abortion
but I especially do not like the idea of
eight thousand instances of infanticide
we've got to stop it
half would walk out at that the other
half would come to the podium and who
didn't come the podium would come when I
said I don't believe that I do believe
that climate changes but I either don't
believe that we're responsible for it or
if we were responsible it justifies the
radical transformations in the economy
that people are calling for I don't
think I could finish that either and if
I said I live in a farmhouse where I
inherited twelve different guns I'm very
proud of them I don't think that would
go over in other words there is a
freedom of speech but if you were to try
to say that if you don't believe me you
wouldn't be able to but you don't
believe me if you all put on red Magga
hats and walk into Detroit see what
happens to you
and so there's cases where we have these
constitutional freedoms but a minority
of the population that has so much more
influence and resources is able to
created culture of shame where we don't
dare exercise them and then de facto
it's almost the same result as the
people formally and legally trying to
invalidate the Constitution or you know
if people don't want to go out and vote
in California because they're afraid to
go to the polls it has the same effect
as a federal judge overturning a club a
site that happened in two cases with gay
marriage let me just finish by saying
what happened what causes this you talk
to people overseas in Asia or Africa
they call it the Western disease and
what they're referring to is a clearly
defined mentality in the ancient world
you can read it in Plato and Aristotle
you can see it especially in Roman
nihilistic literature Tacitus Petronius
metolius that suggests that too much
affluence too much leisure creates a
laxity and luksus the Romans called it
or if you don't have an existential
threat then perhaps you have the margin
of error to indulge and ideas that are
detrimental to yourself even suicidal
notions note that a country like Israel
is Western to the core but it's not as
advanced because it knows if it were to
experiment with either pre-modern
citizenship or postmodern citizenship
it's mortars would be overrun that would
cease to exist because Italy it lives in
a sea of enemies unlike us and most of
Western Europe that's part of it but I
would just end by suggesting that a lot
of it is our educational system because
the people who are crafting our laws the
judges who are overturning plebiscites
the lawyers who are advancing these
legal theories the professors who are
teaching our children all come from a
asymmetrical system and by that I mean
they feel that they have reached a point
of wisdom and affluence and leisure and
comfort and that it's permissible or
indeed it's it's desirable or necessary
to explain to people how unhappy how
miserable they are and
that they must change the system and the
more that they change the system you can
see what's happening whether it's
homeless people in San Francisco
juxtaposed to people in Nob Hill or
Pacific Heights right next to them as
they walk across it there's an asymmetry
that we in the university live one life
tenured affluent leisure and we tell
indebted students you have to do this
with no ramifications of the ideology
affecting ourselves and so I think that
we could leave by thinking there's
nothing better that we all could do than
to support colleges that protect the
Constitution they advocate for the
middle class they make a distinction
between residents and citizens and
they're not just skeptical but they're
adamantly opposed to anybody who wants
to change the US Constitution the last
great hope for mankind and the only
thing that saves not just the United
States but the world at large thank you
very much
I don't know if we have to question you
dr. Manson
we now time for a few questions if you
have a question please up come up to the
microphones
I hope I didn't scare you if you have a
question please come up to a microphone
first of all thank you very much amazing
we enjoy you both in your articles and
on television what is your feeling about
the last 10 days about this so-called
whistleblower issue whistleblower issue
well my wife called me said what are you
going to speak on and she said you're
not gonna speak on that are you and and
then she sighed and said of course you
will be stupid enough to talk well very
quickly
this latest psycho drama is it has it's
in a series isn't it the moments act the
25th amendment
stormy the voting machines Mueller so
it's part of a series that to overturn
not just a 2016 election that but
preclude that 2020 in its in its in a
vain at which which I just talked about
it's an effort to change the
Constitution as it were but there is I
think what Nancy Pelosi has done by
going forward before she even had read
the transcript of the call or the
whistleblower complaint was tactically
very smart because Trump has already
gone down two points we have we
everybody's forgot the UN speech he gave
very good speech and then strategically
very stupid because it accomplished all
at once four or five things that she I
don't think anticipated number one it
took out for all practical purposes the
leading candidate Joe Biden and you
cannot mention Ukraine you can be you
can rail about Trump on Ukraine but at
some point you have to mention Jill
Biden even to say well it doesn't apply
to Joe Biden there that in itself is so
I think that he's taken out and he had
the best chance of defeating don't from
second the whistleblower and the people
who put the whistleblower up and I say
that because I read very carefully the
whistleblowers complaint it's not
written by a normal whistleblower it's a
legal document and - you cannot impeach
the president itíd States based on a
whistleblowers complaint worth nine
times he or she says I was told or I
heard it's all hearsay
I know the Inspector General said there
was some first-hand knowledge I read it
four times I couldn't find any
first-hand knowledge and third you can
impeach the President on anonymous
sources they don't identify those
so-called staffers who heard this call
and of course even if they did hear the
call press the United States can bluster
cajole barter horse bar that's what they
do and can you imagine the phone call
about Barack Obama and the nocturnal
transfer of 400 billion dollars to Iran
I don't want to hear about it but it's
it's his right to do that and so what
I'm getting at is the whistleblower
we're gonna learn who the /
whistleblower is and people are gonna
ask the whistleblower have you ever met
Adam Schiff did you ever have a lawyer
did you know that the whistleblower
statute was changed to allow hearsay
shortly before you filed this have you
communicated with anybody in the DNC
those are gonna be questions under
penalty of perjury and then finally I
think Nancy Pelosi thought that the news
cycle is is predictable you go into
impeachment it makes sense Trump might
when the elections stop it now but it's
not it's volatile and by that I mean
there's too many known unknowns there's
Michael Horowitz with maybe a criminal
indictment of Andrew McCabe there's
Michael Horowitz maybe with the criminal
indictment about the abuse of the FISA
Court there's John Huebner who's going
all over the world trying to find who
interfered against Trump not for Trump
and then you have John Durham is doing
the same thing so you have three
prosecutors who are looking at things
we've never looked at who knows what the
news will be like that we've only had
three a bit is it twelve we have nine
more of these debates I mean every time
there's a
Trump goes up by two points so you and
so what I'm getting at is that going
after and trying to appease a president
on anonymous sources and hearsay while
you have three prosecutors loose and you
have debates going on with the new Green
Deal advocacy and reparation it's not a
good formula I think and I think the
result will be after about three weeks
she'll start to see that and then it'll
be an impeach impeachment inquiry and
not a true impeachment if they were to
vote on it and I think the Republicans
very much want them to vote 30 or 40
House representatives were going to lose
their seats because where we are in
California they some of them won my
district our Republican candidate lost
by 600 votes he won the election by
6,000 and then voter harvesting by
Christmas he lost by 6 and he's running
again and according to the McClatchy
poll he's 12 points ahead and he's
really hammering this and against the
Democratic incumbent thank you very much
the question
[Applause]
dr. Anson it's a supremacist see you I
left Los Pinos California about six
years ago and when I left the city of
35,000 the Ford dealership had cuz I the
Mustang had had was down to four
mechanics and they all left at noon you
said in your book Mexifornia in 20 that
you're out I believe in 2003 203 you
said this state cannot figure out
whether it has become a promised land
based on cheap immigrant labor or a
looming nightmare of unassimilated
third-world ISM now the reason I think
that's so critical and I'd like to have
more comment on that from you is because
as you say in your book what's happening
there is coming to the rest of us
that was a funny book because the person
who asked me to write the article from
which the book came 20 years ago said
can you write how wonderfully illegal
immigration is and I said I can write
about it but it won't be wonderful so I
think what we saw in California in 2002
3 when I wrote that is happening all
over the country and it's based what
changed and by that I mean we all have
this I guess in our business we all have
this bloodsport where we go back and
look at YouTube comments if you've seen
John Kerry Hillary Clinton Bill Clinton
blasting illegal immigration you should
do it there's a great one with Barack
Obama says I'm not a king I can't I
can't give amnesty 22 times he said that
so what changed and what changed is
people said that in the Democratic Party
when there were two four and six million
but when you have 20 million and you
have a second generation already that's
at voting age of another 10 or 15
million of US citizens then that's a
powerful constituency and they look at
California and they say wow this was 32
years of Reagan Pete Wilson that masion
Schwarzenegger never gonna happen again
super majority in both legislatures we
went down from 53 congressional seats to
7 Republican so they look at Nevada
flipped New Mexico's flip blew Texas and
Arizona and Colorado we're next and
that's a demographic shift so the
Democratic Party is for open borders
because they find a lot of advantage the
only thing that's going to save us is
what we talk about citizenship that we
appeal to people who were coming
hopefully legally hopefully with skills
hopefully the America attic process
hopefully in a diverse manner so they're
from all over the world and we say to
them you left your country you don't
like Oaxaca you may think you like
Oaxaca
you may put a Mexican flag on your car
but you're here so that tells me you did
not like it there so we're here to help
you
we're here to integrate you and
assimilate you in
and become one of us and if Trump can
make that argument and he can also make
economic argument I have got he could
say I got the lowest unemployment in the
history of the Mexican American
workforce it's true and for someone who
lives in that area it's just absolutely
astounding to hear people come up to you
and say I was on the wolf they're paying
me $19 an hour
for the first time in my life Victor a
guy came over and got out of his car and
said I'll pay you 23 if you get off that
roof and go on my roof and he said they
want me now and so what we forgot in the
Republican Party that the essence of
dignity is a job and when you get the
unemployment rate down to 3.7 and you
have employers begging for workers that
worker calculates that and thinks I have
dignity now I have leverage and I want
to I I have some gratitude to the person
who did that so wouldn't that be ironic
that through economics and a new
approach to mexican-american voters one
based on citizenship and become one of
us
the Democratic Party would lose what
they need to win and because they've so
alienated the working classes especially
the white working-class they cannot
afford to lose 40 percent the Hispanic
vote or even 15 percent of the black
vote and yet I think there's a good
chance they'll do both
questions since your book carnage and
culture and what's happened today if you
were to go back or to look at what you
wrote then and what is happening now
what are the underpinnings in your
opinion being a student of culture that
gives us foundation or perhaps a way or
a path back to culture that will remain
as strong as our Constitution intended
well when you say the West Western
culture were really we have to be
specific we're talking about North
America Canada in the United States and
we're talking about Britain's and its
former Empire in most part Australia
Canada New Zealand and we're talking
about continental Europe and then we're
now talking about westernized states
such as South Korea or Taiwan or Japan
that are more or less accepted the
paradigm and out of you know seven
billion people there's about two billion
that are on that page and so that that's
helpful but what is worried to me is
that while globalization and
westernization has swept the globe so if
I go to the Ukraine or I go to Bolivia
people have jeans they have a cell phone
they're on Facebook they seem dumb
they're almost quasi Americans that
diffusion has really weakened the West
and by that I mean people think the West
is that x-men movie I saw or the West is
that cellphone as I said or it's that
particular rap song it's not it's a menu
of constitutional government free speech
due process the protection of private
property the right to bear arms and that
menu is I think I don't want to be too
too fanatical or too paranoid but I
think that menu is almost gone in Europe
as I see it today and and you can see
what's happening in brexit today when
people
had a pleb site we do not want to be
part of this continental system it's
different than we in Britain it's not
the anglo-saxon Langan tradition the
Atlantians Atlantic it's different we
don't want it anymore
it's anti-democratic it's against the
traditions of Britain and they can't get
out because their own elites have joined
the Continental System so what I'm most
worried about when I wrote about carnage
and culture I use that word the West and
I know that there's been bifurcations
during World Wars but what's really
scary is that we're going to an
Orwellian sameness in the West and the
United States is not completely against
it half of the United States agrees with
the trajectory that Europe is in and
they like the European Union and they
like the idea that somebody in Brussels
can tell a Greek that that's not a
banana because it's not six inches long
or you can't go to your beach because
one of our inspectors saw a plastic
bottle so we shut it down they liked
that control because they feel that a
special a special educated affluent
class mostly on the coast of the United
States and Europe and the big cities
knows far better than the average person
what's good for them and to the degree
that they're wrong they have a parachute
by their own influence and wealth that
their bromides will never apply to them
themselves and that's what's really
scary because the United States is built
on this middle class match word with
deed and I always want my mother was the
the first female Superior Court judge in
California I mean in Fresno County and a
second female appellate court judge and
I had a grandfather that mortgaged his
ranch with very little money
little tiny farm and put all his
children to college and to in the 1940s
for graduate undergraduate Stanford I
remember her going to the farmers market
when she was a pellet court judge
peddling pears and plums with us on
Saturdays out there with a you know an
apron on and I'd say well Wow
judge Hanson's out here making fun of my
mother and she said it's very very
important to remember that
in America the elite get their hands
dirty and I'm elite only in title I'm
not part of that and that was very
important that we realize that physical
work has dignity and that people who
work with our hands and are in the
middle class or the the bulwark of this
country they have a common sense that is
invaluable to this country we forgot
that and almost forgot that until 2016
and when I I'm not gonna get political
but when Trump for the first time said
our workers our vets our I like the word
our when he went to I mean he was
ridiculous he went to West Virginia and
Hillary had said we're gonna shut you
all down and have to make solar panels
essentially and he said I love big
beautiful coal so what I'm getting at is
that I don't see that I see a Marxist
paradigm between workers and then
capitalists in Europe but what I see in
America was always a reverence for the
working-class just right from Jefferson
from the beginning of the Constitution
and we've really got to get back to the
idea that none of us are above the idea
of physical work when you have somebody
build your roof or mow your lawn that's
just as important as what we're doing up
here in this stage and we really have to
get that dignity and respect back for
muscular labor in this outsourcing
offshoring globalist economy we forgot
that and I think we've been saved at the
last moment
should we invite a thousand Venezuelans
to live in each one of our congressional
districts to remind us of the
alternative did you hear the question to
invite I think we don't need them we
have enough professors
and look for how we are in time
I very much enjoyed your speech whatever
presentation you mentioned that the idea
of maybe their senators having the same
representation as representatives now
about six to eight months ago there was
a writer and I think it was a Wall
Street Journal that predicted the
Democrats would have a difficult time in
the future ever getting the Senate back
and I don't remember the logic and I was
wondering if you would read that article
or know why he made that assertion I
mean we don't want to be pull off a FERS
but there is a mentality behind all this
if you think about it so if the
Democrats don't have when they are in
the minority of course when they're in
the majority they don't want filibusters
filibusters are archaic and disruptive
when they're in the minority they want
to bring them back
if believe me if Donald Trump wins the
popular vote and Elizabeth Warren wins
the electoral college electoral college
will be the greatest thing since sliced
bread and the same thing with senators
if tomorrow we have a hundred Democratic
senators and they're going to say this
is the best system the founders ever
came up on so what I'm getting at is
that I don't really take the left at its
word I don't think they have a
consistent philosophy other than we
believe in equality of result we're
morally superior because we have greater
empathy and therefore because we're
morally superior creatures to you any
means necessary any inconsistencies is
allowable because our aims are so much
greater than your greedy individualist
profit-mongering selfishness and that's
how they operate and therefore when we
look at this impeachment circus and I'm
talking about people my own family
when you talk to them the details don't
matter what all that matters is these
are people who are out to help people
and they're trying to oppose people who
are selfish and therefore anything that
goes on is justified and that's been the
that's been the story of progressivism
and lept ISM since antiquity we have
time for one more question
thank you very much you've been a
historian and studied history over the
millennia not your millennia but there
was plenty yeah can you is there any
other comparable time in other
civilizations that went through what
we're going through now and their
outcome and how would you foresee the
United States in ten years compared to
how additional ization have worked out
these problems you know I think the
greatest treatise that's ever been
written on politics is Aristotle's
politics because he transcends the
particular case studies that he adduce
isn't what he just assumes is there's
always going to be class struggle or
political struggle between different
groups and if I could reduce that to a
banality it's there's some people who
believe in a equality of opportunity and
some believe in a state-mandated
equality result the people who believe
in the quality of opportunities say this
unfortunately we weren't all born
equally some of us have more talent some
of us have better health some of us have
better luck some of us had a rich
grandfather life is unfair but let us go
and do our thing and then we will have
social pressures like you people here to
give back let me go make a lot of money
and then let me choose to help support
Hillsdale I will do that are not a
greedy person there's only so hot that
my shower can get my BMW only goes so
fast I can't spend all that I'm gonna
make up but I want to do it for a
variety of reasons and that that group
is usually attacked by people who for
various reasons in the Plato and
Aristotle were no dummies they talk
about psychological reasons that people
get envious envious
envy and jealousy he's easy etcetera the
two of the most powerful emotions we
have the other people say we can't trust
those people they don't give in a way
that's it's that's rational or moral so
we want to take what they have
and distribute it to the more noble
people and that dichotomy is the story
of Western civilization and when it
works we keep it within the boundaries
and we have certain ground rules that
you shall not resort to violence
you shall relegate politics to a
secondary level and you will absorb it
with nationalist pride and collective
patriotism but every once in a while
Rome in the first century when we had a
terrible civil war or the status at
Coursera and Thucydides or two or three
times before the Civil War but
especially during the u.s Civil War or
during the 60s I can remember being at
UC Santa Cruz and a lecture just like
this in 1971 and Jasper Rose a
distinguished art historian was
lecturing to people ran up and tore his
the the exhibits he had down and stepped
on and said we don't want FF your Bush
was ER at certain times we've had these
people who did not want to play by the
rules and sometimes on both sides and
it's incumbent upon all of us to say
whatever our disagreements are about
this ancient divide we want to instruct
you while you're wrong and we want to do
it through persuasion and love and the
people who don't want to do that
unfortunately are gonna have to pay a
price and human nature being what it is
most people don't have very much courage
so believe me if we had courageous
university presidents outside of
Hillsdale and we had courageous Police
Chief and the first time a 94 protester
went up on stage and hit somebody these
people are not rebels believe me there
are upper middle class kids that have
all the career ambitions of anybody else
if you charge him with a felony assault
and that was on his record that would be
the last time he ever did that there is
such a thing as deterrence but what
we've had now is we've allowed this
ancient debate to get way beyond the old
parameters and it's starting to get
violent and it's starting to get absurd
and started to get nasty because we
don't have
people who were courageous enough to
step in and say that you're not going to
do that anymore there's a role of law in
the Constitution until we return to that
it's going to spiral out of control and
we just need one or two honest people to
stand up and say no more so far we
haven't found them thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]